our guest today dee wallace is an
internationally celebrated actress you
may recognize from the howling howling
Cujo the house of the devil and et in
addition to her acting she also serves
as a healer she has authored three books
conscious creation the Big E and their
upcoming bright light which is due here
in 2011 she specializes in discerning
blocks beliefs and fears that are
sabotaging our conscious choices
creating joy and flow miss Wallace has
been featured on oprah The O'Reilly
Factor good morning america The Today
Show and many others she has appeared in
over a hundred and fifty films five TV
series and many TV shows she is listed
in the who's who in America and has a BA
in education from the University of
Kansas for more on D please visit
official dee wallace calm and with that
please welcome to the film courage show
miss Dee Wallace hello wow what a life
enjoy guys hey hey thank you so much
thank you so much for joining us d you
know as we mentioned to you when we
connected just before the show we really
felt like the universe was calling us to
you you know we saw you on the red
carpet this summer at Holly shorts we
saw you in mother of invention one of
the film's we featured at our film
courage interactive we saw you in the
house of the devil so we just really
felt like the universe was was putting
you in front of us and that we needed to
reach out to you well I'm glad you did
because you know there's no mistakes in
the world so we're supposed to be here
in this moment with all of the energy
and people that are participating so
it's all in perfect order and I'm let's
establish first off where you grew up
and what life was like for you in the
beginning okay well in a nutshell I grew
up in Kansas City Kansas i was there
literally until i left at the ripe age
of i think it was around 27 and when I
went to New York by myself never been
out of Kansas before I was raised in a
fairly religious household
and yet the dichotomy of that was we
were always encouraged to be very real
and very authentic and you know for
example my mother was raised as a
Southern Baptist and turned Methodist
when she married my dad and wanted me to
have dance lessons which of course we
could not tell my grandmother because
she was a super bad so that's kind of
the dichotomy of wow don't do all this
creative stuff shh don't tell grandma
and we were we were pretty poor most of
my life we lived with my grandmother
bowers my my paternal grandmother and we
rented the downstate well she rented the
house and we lived in the downstairs my
father wouldn't alcoholic couldn't hold
down a job and such an amazing creative
just a beautiful creative man and pretty
much has created creativeness get him in
which i'm sure a lot of people can kind
of associate that with with that
illusion that created people have to
suffer which I'm inviting everybody to
let go of today because it ain't true
unless you believe it's true and
ultimately he committed suicide behind a
bar when I was a senior in high school
so um you know I that being said he
would dance with me every Saturday night
when we watch the hit parade and what I
was nostalgically watching the Miss
America pageant last night for a while
because my mother and father and I would
watch it every year and my dad would
look at me and go that note you can do
that you can do that you can be missing
so you know there was this yin and yang
constantly in in my life of you can
watch out maybe you can't you can watch
out maybe you better stay in Kansas you
know and and I think most of us are
challenged by that duality of messages
that we get from our families and our
churches in our society you know until
you realize that you are listening to do
allottees and it can really screw your
focus up and pull you out of the focus
of creatively completing your life so in
a nutshell in a nutshell that was it my
grandmother pretty much raised me my mom
had to work all the time my mother was
an amazing actress but she was you know
an actress in community plays and and
created all of the plays at church I
started out as baby Jesus and ended up
as Mary Magdalene so spirituality and
acting and creativity have always been
greatly invest coming together and let's
go back to what you said about this
illusion that most creative people face
what is that illusion oh i thought you
know creatives have to struggle I mean
you know a van Gogh and all all the
stories we've heard and romanticized
about and you know like I mean you know
I teach one master acting class in LA
and I used to have one of the largest
studios and I would have people coming
and I do a lot of this healing work
about getting to what your blocks are
and everything in my acting studio and
over and over and over and some
machination of the belief would come
about that yeah but I can't make it for
five years I can't make it for ten years
I have to wait tables first I you know
they're against me and I'm going to have
to work my way up and you know it's just
the governing rule guys is as you
believe it's going to be delivered to
you so you better watch out what your
beliefs are around the creative process
whether you're a writer or director and
actor focus on what you want
and what you want is a free joyous
creative life that comes easily and
effortlessly right and and pays you a
lot of money come on we like many so
many creative people put up this wall
about you know they they can't be truly
creative and spiritual and make money at
the same time like money has some kind
of consciousness of its own you know
many only carries with it the
consciousness that you are i'm doing a
two-hour live seminar at spirit work on
the twenty-sixth of january all about
money and consciousness and how it
screws up our creativity so let's go
back to the plays you left Kansas and
you went to New York City how did your
acting career progress like a lightning
bolt okay well truthfully I I was just
so naive you see that I I didn't have
any expectations that it was supposed to
be hard so I got in the first time I
auditioned for una Hagen and I had
written a letter to how prints from well
I was a school teacher for a year and in
the library we got the new york times
and there was this article that how
prince was looking for an unknown to
star in a little night music so i'm
learning the letter and three weeks
later I got a call and his secretary
said well mr. prince would like to fly
you in to audition now this is how naive
I was and I'm not a real blonde so it's
not about that it's just about my good
old Kansas naivete which has served me
very well I must say in my life and I
went oh gosh that's so nice but I
already have a chicken you know I get it
gone for advice so the blame I landed in
New York City I took every belonging
that I had brought with me put it in a
taxicab and said
here could you take it to this address I
have an audition and it got there my
stuff got to my apartment I as soon as I
landed in New York City schlepped off to
Rockefeller Center audition for an
operant it's a fabulous story guys I got
down to the last five girls in acting
and the dancing and then they said okay
well we'd like to hear you sing and I
went oh well nobody told me I had to
think aneesa's well dear it is a musical
my birthday in New York I sing happy
birthday for our Prince but the PNA said
what Kenny and I said I don't know
somewhere in the middle it cracks me up
but you know I was off I've met a lot of
professionals I found a top singing
teacher that day couple of people said
oh come talk to my agent will help you
out you know at for four months later I
had I don't know something like nine
dollars left in my name and I had met a
guy at an audition and he took me to a
halloween party and at the Halloween
party were his agent well I didn't know
who they were you know I just dewas
Deanna bowers from Kansas and I just
like to talk to everybody any event so
at the end of the night they said oh my
god we so love you come to the office we
want to talk about it to you about
working with you and I went oh good what
do you do well they were the merge
fields agency which was one of the
largest commercial agencies in
theatrical in town at the time so they
booked me and I literally almost took a
day for months landed my first national
commercial for United Airlines I had
around nine dollars left my older
brother was going to loan me some and
that commercial over that year I ended
up making thirty thousand dollars Wow
well now let me tell you Vienna bars in
Kansas thought she died and gone to
heaven good
but that's what I mean I you know I was
brought up as a dancer so I went to
audition for all the industrial shows
and booked a lot of them the Milliken
show which is the largest industrial
that's how i got my Equity card and it
was just boom boom boom two years later
I went to Los Angeles you know and there
was a big joke at the time the actor
from New York and the actor from LA met
in Mid American said go back go back
there's no work but I got out in here
and ran into a friend again and he said
look you do a lot of commercials and I
got a theatrical agent so I'll set you
up an appointment you set me up so we
did and we got sign I mean it was just
it literally a little over four years
from when I left Kansas I ended up doing
18 you know and from there d you know
you go on to the streets of San
Francisco the Stepford Wives the howling
et Cujo I mean it goes on and on and on
at what point in your career did things
that really begin to skyrocket and you
had this moment where you said wow this
is really happening you know my answer
would have to be it was just a continual
expansion I think probably the biggest
of those moments was when I landed this
part on the grant called the hooker it
was a huge guest star role and the night
vetted aired I got a call the next
morning from limb stall masters office
who was the biggest casting director at
the time and they had been looking for
this part for Blake Edwards film 10 and
couldn't find it and they wanted me this
is the last day of casting and they
wanted me to come over and I went over
and by the time I got to my car
afterwards I'd been booked for the role
so I would say that probably when I went
oh wow I have a shot at the big time now
you know
but it was the way I got my first job I
did what we do in Kansas when you want
to go meet people you bake cookies so I
baked a bunch of chocolate chip cookies
and wrapped them all up and put them in
nice little packages because you
couldn't get on the Lots back man at all
for anything and I drove up to the guy
and fluttered my little blue eyes and
said i have several deliveries for the
casting directors and he said okay honey
go on in so i spent the whole day
walking r and universal taking chocolate
chip cookies civic casting directors and
i was there and um leaving some offer
ruben cannon who was oh my god what's a
name of the show now they had Hartman
and and he was casting that he came out
he went Oh chocolate chip cookies and I
said hi I'm Dee Wallace I just got here
from Kansas even though it was New York
Kansas was a much better line and he
said we'll come on in and so we SAT
there and talked and literally while I
was dead they got a call from the set
that the actress had called in sick and
getting a little co-star thing and he
looked at me and he said what size are
you wear and I said what size do you
need sorry Tammy already said I stuffed
myself into this size 6 costume and that
was my first credit in LA and it's just
that I ran into a friend and his friend
was directing streets of San Francisco
and they needed somebody to be raped I
said on the grapes cream or I can do
that and so we called his friend and
they hired me without an audition I mean
with inverted stuff like this but that's
what I mean if if you don't think it
can't happen and you just hold the
intention that it is happening that
you're creating it happening the
universe can bring it about in the most
bizarre wonderful ways but you can't get
in the way so you know it was just it
was just a glorious
run all the way up through ET and then
it kind of stopped this is film courage
we are on the line with actress healer
and author dee wallace Saudi your career
and your life crosses over into a new
dimension in this phase that you just
referred to I'm sure you have more
people approaching you you're in demand
what are some of the things about this
kind of success that people don't
realize both the positive and the
negative um I think the biggest negative
is I stopped listening to myself and I
always knew and we always know and then
we you know they're going where you
can't do that you know and well no now
we need to choose this and well that
director isn't big enough instead of
just always going with my heart which is
what I always did and saying oh I have
to do this I feel this I feel this part
and I think that's the biggest that was
the biggest negative for me was losing
my own voice and going maybe they know
more and maybe I should trust them and
and staying balanced you know not buying
into all the BS i remember when i got my
review and variety and i was so excited
and i called my end beloved husband
Christopher stone who had a very
successful career already established
and I'm reading the review and he looked
at me with lebanese and hunting just
remember if you believe the good ones
you got to believe the bad ones and I've
never forgotten that in other words
you're the only one that knows you know
if you know if you showed up you know if
you committed you know if you've done a
great job you don't need them to tell
you and I think that's a big principle
of the creative life right there is you
we all have to know guys we have to know
where writers we have to know where
directors we have to know where actors I
can't walk into Steven Spielberg's
office and go well hi Steven I don't
know
I can do this part I I think I might be
able to emotionally do some of this
stuff and I I don't really know if I'm
an actor but would you give me deleting
your film and that's kind of what we're
doing with the universe and with our
careers a lot of time is we're well when
they hire me I'll know well you got it
backwards guys you've got to know and
then you get hired so the do whatever
you can do to know that you're ready to
know that you're talented to know that
you're creative because as soon as that
shift happens in you then all the
universe runs forever to go yet you are
yet you are so I and and the other the
other thing that was so hard for me is
it doesn't make sense none of it makes
sense doesn't make sense you know that I
start in the biggest blockbuster of all
time and then my career fell off it
doesn't make sense but it makes sense
once you understand that principle that
as you believe it will be delivered to
you so I had a lot of beliefs which is
this is again in some of the stuff that
I work with in class and and on the show
conscious creation that I had a lot of
beliefs that Deanna Bowers could only go
so far Deanna Bowers could only have so
much success Deanna Bowers could only
make so much money and then it couldn't
happen anymore name there were a lot of
beliefs I mean I've watched my father
lived that over and over and over in his
life he would create an idea and
somebody would steal it from him and he
he would start a business and something
would sabotage it so the message to me
was I get right up there to the creation
of me and all its glory and then
somebody or something takes it away so
if i had that belief i had to create
that in my life and i did that
beautifully I might say I was a really
great creator around that and so if
there's a gift that
I can give any of your listeners today
it's know who you are no you're worth no
Your Magnificence love yourself and keep
focused on that because when you know it
the universe has got a magic thank you
get the law it's literally a law thank
you for that you know and expanding on
that a little bit décor something that
often goes through my mind is you know
you know care and I we worked so hard at
what we do here you know and sometimes
it goes through am I like if we can just
get to a certain point if we can just
reach a certain level of success then
then it's going to get easier you know
it is that true i mean that does it ever
get any easier it only gets easier if
you make it easier nail you see it's not
about anything outside of you so in this
moment right now you have a choice of
going okay well it's easy I love
everything I do I have time to do
everything I do and I'm going to choose
that in my happiness and my joy of doing
what I get to do it's easy and then your
energy shifts and then every do you
understand you're the center of your
universe when you shift the universe
that's within you the universe outside
of you must shift to mirror and
magnetize them so you know no matter
what's going on guys we have the choice
to be happy now that may sound like a
Pollyanna comment but if you truly want
to know how to change your life and get
what you want be what you want first
because it can't happen until you are
the being and the feeling and the
expression of it Katy Perry has an
amazing video out right now call
firework you should go to youtube and
watch it because it's all about it comes
with it from within you and you and once
you find it within yourself it explodes
out into the world into this firework of
celebration that the universe recognizes
and that segue is perfectly into a
wonderful quote that you have on your
IMDB page and you say I'm the girl next
door who learned how to make life work
the hard way I lived it victim to
victory when you find the joy you have
to share it can you tell us how you came
about proclaiming this in your life you
know many people they stay in victimhood
it's easy to and they don't move forward
yeah it's it's we think it's easy
because that's what we've always known
but man when you get on the other side
you went dude I just hear all that time
holy how I thought it was easy and it
was hella path and he'll a diamond I
didn't know it so yeah I am I had been
hurt and a lot in the business and
intentional by some people I had was my
beloved Christopher after 18 years of
marriage and I was pissed off I was
pissed I've been pissed for about 20
years I think and 19 I shall I put my
beautiful daughter to bed and was
overwhelmed with anger and fear and you
know anger is a secondary emotion of
underneath it's either griefer fear
which I had a lot of both of and I just
fell to my knees and railing at God
wherever whoever it was and I said I
don't want to be this way anymore I
don't want to be a victim I don't want
to be angry I I don't want to be afraid
I want my life back and I want a way we
can heal ourselves well lemme Jaya in
that moment I certainly got the
experience of asking you receive because
it's like this huge zipper opened up and
all this information started pouring in
and that was now
Oh 12 14 years ago is when all this
started and at the time I had one of the
largest studios I had ongoing 70 to 80
students at any one time and it's like
the universe gave me my own little test
group and I started bringing some of
this work into class and I had all of
these amazingly dedicated beautiful
students we learned a lot about acting
but man we learned a lot about the
creation of ourselves and the work
that's expanded and expanded and
expanded I am dedicated my first book
concerts creation to all the beautiful
students i had that helped me create
that and it's just ongoing and i had a
person on one of my shows as me when do
I know I'm bairdi and the answer that
was channeled was you'll know you're
there when you know it's a process of
ongoing into forever just greater
understanding deeper understanding more
expansion more remembering of everything
we know it doesn't end it just goes on
and we are speaking with actress healer
and author dee wallace on your acting
studio site dee wallace calm is it you
have various lessons you offer actors
from breaking down a scene comedy acting
exercises one can do and the first
lesson it looks like you offer is on
energy and you walk yeah and it appears
that you're very passionate about it and
it reads acting is energy this lesson
teaches you how to raise your energy so
your instinct and intuition take over it
teaches you how to throw and receive
energy and the basic heat all acting can
you tell us more about that energy
exchange yeah thank you those are my
online classes which are really quite
affordable and the first one is free
guys this first one that she's talking
about is free so um well everything is
energy your energy I'm energy there
isn't anything of energy so what the
camera loves is watching
that exchange of energy between two
people you know when they they say oh
the two stars had had such a connection
you know that's what they're talking
about is they're sending out energy to
each other which which the bill partner
is receiving allowing it to affect them
and then sending back the energy of that
response a lot of actors and a lot of
creative people and stand back and watch
themselves instead of sending out the
energy and for actors that's death if
you're not if you're not sending out
your energy to connect with someone the
camera doesn't come as alive and that's
where most of us fall down in our
auditions we get an audition and we go
over and over and over and over it and
then we go into the room and we pull our
energy back out kind of back out the
back of our head so that we can watch to
see if we've done what we did at home
and how well we're doing and that's
death on camera you've got to take the
energy and push it forward so that it's
all about the person you're connecting
with whether it's a green screen or a
casting director or another actor your
energy has to be propelling forward and
you can't do that if you're in your head
watching to see if you're doing okay so
when you and the principle of my
technique is is getting your energy very
very very very high and when you do that
you surpass your mental faculties and
you allow the energy to be channeled
through you so that you're always in
this heightened awareness of the moment
and you know amazing
amazing information comes into you
amazing hits amazing emotional life I
say to everybody if you're going in to
audition and you got to hit an emotional
level don't think about it don't try to
get there get your energy up energy up
and breathe the best thing you can do to
open up your creative channel before you
right before you direct before you act
before anything is deep reading and we
literally practice on that first lesson
we practice and I show you what it feels
like when I really connect with the
camera and when I pull back if you're an
actor you know you've worked with actors
that you literally can be 5 inches from
and you're looking right at him but
there's no energy that it's like trucks
could go through that little slide in
space between the two of you because
that guy's not connecting with you at
all or you're not connecting with him
and it's it's it's hugely recognizable
on screen and for those of you that go
into audition you can imagine then that
the director is watching this let these
tapes later if your energy is not
connecting with the camera and going
through the camera or to the person that
you're reading with when he's trying to
connect with you when he's watching the
tape there's no connection happening so
there's no magic for him and you're
probably not gonna get going back being
in the entertainment industry living in
Los Angeles how do we not allow
ourselves to be swayed by chaotic energy
you know I mean it's tough you're going
to auditions there's traffic you're
rushing around how do we allow outside
energy if it's negative not to seep into
our personal space as a sensitive
creature you know you're the creation of
you guys so it's all up to you you're
again in choice every moment so if you
don't want to be praised by the traffic
leave earlier do stuff to support
yourself and and it's all about balance
all about balance so if you don't want
to be swayed by the negative energy then
what do you want we want to keep
balanced in the positive energy so if
your focus is on fixing all the
then you will have more Bolsheviks if
your focus is on ease and effortlessness
and balance then that is what you will
attract to you so you you can't get what
you want by fixing what you don't you
got it yeah yeah and that's where most
of us fall out in the creative process I
swear to God I can have people come up
in seminars and I'll say okay so tell me
what you want I don't want to have to
worry about money anymore okay so tell
me what you want well I don't want to be
stressed over money so what do you want
aye aye aye and they can't tell me
because the only way they can express
what they want is to tell me what they
don't want I want money that's what I
want first of all most of us are taught
don't you dare say that it's okay to say
we want abundance well you know it's
just more BS we all want money we like
money many allows the world to be
created more easily and effortlessly if
we so believe it some people who have a
lot of money believe it or not think
money creates more chaos in their lives
so again it's not about the money it's
about your consciousness and how you
connect your beliefs to the money often
times when i'm doing a private about
money and they have all these oh my god
to blaze you know every lucre and money
root of all evil and I shouldn't have
more than what i need that was a good
old Midwestern teaching that I was you
know just have enough that's all you
need or was enough enough for me is I
get to go to Hawaii for a year and I
mean for a week every year and I hope a
year would be nice and I get to have
enough to take my family's out to nice
dinners and do great Christmases and go
to the spa for you once in a long get a
nice massage not just paying my bill
that's not what I mean by enough so you
got to look at your definition there but
I I'd say put a bunch of money in the
middle of the floor for two hours and
watch all the bad it does you know
money's just paper until your
consciousness decides how you want to
define it so I say show me the money and
and let me practice worth the
consciousness an unconditional love and
joy and freedom and bliss what I'm going
to do with it you know we're talking
money we're talking about attracting
wealth into our lives I mean they often
say that that people who have amassed
great wealth if there were if the wealth
was stripped away from them that these
individuals would be able to start over
again and recreate the wealth in regards
to your career in this business d what
if you were 26 again today and you were
starting over from scratch you know that
there is sunny there are so many more
actors today that it's so much more
competitive than it was I'm turning 30
years ago good moline would you be able
to recreate it all over again yeah that
is one belief that will be their undoing
right there so much harder today so many
more accurate so you know I heard the
same damn thing when I came out here I
heard the same thing we've been telling
ourselves the same stories guys
creatively those of us who are creative
well it's like it's urban legend it's
been handed down and and that's our you
see that's our challenge
do you still want to define it that way
or do you want to know and this is the
answer to your question I have a
beautiful incredible incredibly talented
daughter who's 22 who's just starting
her career just starred in her first
film yeah and grows with me and and I
tell her and I tell my students every
day yes learning how to act but more
importantly learn the specifics of
creation because that is what it's all
about I don't care if you act right
direct sell shoes wait tables I don't
care what it is create it the way you
want it to be and if you don't know the
principles of creation it will apply to
anything you do because you've got to
create yourself first and then that
stuff you do gets created so most of us
know what we don't want so if you don't
if you know what you don't want you know
what you want start there make a list of
all the crap you don't want and then
opposite make a list of the positive
that you want and then from that moment
on don't ever focus on anything but the
positive list and whenever you focus on
it go okay what what makes me feel great
good sex makes me feel great great I
know that feeling that's the kind of
feeling I want the great sex feeling the
high the orgasm around are these things
on my list what else makes me feel great
well in my life my god the birth of my
daughter royal neural pathway lights up
I want to feel that way about all those
things on my list that's what I'm
choosing to be and that's my direction
to the universe in all the
has all the auditions all the agents I
need all the casting directors other
people I do interviews for I want to
feel like that and that's it that is
what you do day in and day out listen to
Jim Carrey go on at her studio at the
very end he says dream as big as you can
dream imagine your career as big as you
can imagine because you're the creation
of it and that's what I would say to
every creative person listening on this
show start within you can't be pissed
off at the business and want to be a
part of it the energy doesn't match up
you can't say you screw the testing
drugs in the agent you know nobody oh I
army and blah blah blah I don't need
them anyway and this business is so hard
and then turn around and go please
universe could I have a job right
doesn't match up and flying my baptist
preacher came out there for a minute no
it's beautiful what I love it we have so
many more questions and unfortunately
this is our last one but it it segues
perfectly into we had casting director
Bonnie Gillespie on and she came up with
this great term got body by the way oh
she's wonderful and in it she she called
it bitter actor syndrome and I think
we've all been there and and you know
we're working a survival job we're
seeing other people maybe move ahead and
and ourselves were stuck and so we get
into this mindset how do we embrace
gratitude when maybe the actual tangible
things in our lives aren't giving us
something to be grateful for okay well
there's a lot of BS talk about gratitude
and and I talked about that in conscious
creation gratitude is a state of
beingness so you know just what service
it's not gratitude gratitude is an
overwhelming filling up of love and
appreciation at the moment that you're
in
now if you're pissed off and angry it's
pretty hard to feel gratitude so the
first place you want to start is I'm
going to choose to feel gratitude i am
going to direct myself through my
choices that this is what i want i want
to be the feeling of gratitude
everywhere in my life that's what I want
that's what I'm choosing because most of
us are going okay kitchen should happen
to me here so I can be gratis in
gratitude and again doesn't work that
way guys it works why you being in
gratitude for absolutely nothing for the
greatness of your beingness that you
chose to be here for the magnificence of
the God that you are because you are and
when you really start loving yourself
and loving yourself and loving yourself
and loving yourself then you cannot not
experience gratitude because the more
you love yourself the more you will love
the world and everything in it go to the
universe of you it's all about you I'm
giving you permission to make it all
about you and how magnificent you are
and start by looking in the mirror and
going you're awesome dude I love you you
are awesome let's create and that would
be my answer and the more you live in
true love and appreciation for the
beingness that you are the more
gratitude you will have and the more
experiences of gratitude that you have
and it doesn't take a very big thing
really doesn't take a very big thing at
all when your heart is filled with love
so remember why you wanted to do this
creative thing that is driving you and
go do it anywhere you can don't wait for
them create you and go do it thank you
yeah thank you beautiful you know we can
see why after being able to spend 50
minutes with the hair d we can see why
we were drawn to your energy you know
and speaking speaking on behalf of our
audience something this this has been
such a blessing for us thank you for for
taking you know portion of your
afternoon to share all this with us I
think this one's going to be one we're
gonna have to go back and listen to this
one well and anybody that wants to reach
me and my email is conscious creation
101 @ yahoo.com and my website is
official dee wallace com all right we
understand to you can go to Toto
enterprises com for some of your books
tapes and merchandise is that right yeah
thank you okay and also like we're not
in Kansas anymore toto that's great and
also you can hear Dion voice of a mayor
or voice america.com for DS radio
program conscious creation and that can
be heard thursdays at eight a.m. pacific
standard time on the seventh wave
network and i believe it's also archived
on the site yes it's on iTunes what it's
all over the place so if you want to
direct link you can get it at official
be Wallace on the healing side wonderful
and then where can people find out about
the acting list you can find all of that
at officials e-wallet online classes and
if anybody's interested in my master
class out here they can email me at
conscious creation 101 @ yahoo.com
wonderful thank you so much for your
time today oh thank you what a great
interview guide thank you so much